hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it is time for another elusive target
look-see target number 20 the Warlord's
I won't even attempt to pronounce this
young lady's name now right for this
mission what do we need all we need is
to change our starting location we're
going to start as hotel security that's
it
easy enough here we go okay the first
thing we're gonna do is not really we're
going to run inside the right hand side
and upstairs one of the things I always
forget is to take out security cameras
as you can see on top left corner it
says we've been recorded by security so
we're going to run over to the room on
the far right here because there is a
master key card just in here which makes
things so much easier so grab hold of
that we'll be coming back here very soon
to pick up the memory stick that we need
for this part of the mission but in the
meantime what we're going to do is just
a lock this door
[Music]
and over there there is the surveillance
equipment so we're just going to whip
out our gun and yeah just that black box
just about there gonna shoot that and
then we're going to scoot back on our
way right we're going to the other side
of the hotel now so it's just around
here down these stairs straight forward
don't worry about these two guards here
easy enough just drug straight past them
right we're going up another set of
stairs and you should recognize it it's
where you can start in the suite if you
want it to be going to do it that way
and what we're going to do is run past
our room and go to the second room and
it's a bit of a waiting game now once
you've unlocked this room we're waiting
for one of the serving staff to come up
over and hear the television so we can
steal his uniform
so it's a bit of a wait so I'll sing to
you in the meantime right now he is
searching virals or rather he's going to
have a look at the TV so we'll leave him
be remember to let him turn the TV off
before we subdue him or another thing as
well when she once he is subdued drag
his body out of the way because when you
leave this room sometimes there are two
police officers across the hall they can
notice his dead body from a mile away
so first drag him over to the left hand
side of the room just a bit ultra safe
once that's done slip on his clothes and
we are going to take out our target so
upstairs we go
that woman just there we just walked
past she's important to this but I'll
tell you about that soon let's just to
get this out of the way right running to
the right and you're going to go
upstairs be careful there is one young
lady who will notice you so straight up
past her if you can and we're gone in
that room just in front so to get there
we're going to go around the houses so
to speak it's just much safer going in
this direction right it's another
waiting game now this room our target
will come to this room very soon and we
can take her out so again it's another
waiting game sadly so once she comes in
the room I will come back okie dokie
she's at the top of the stairs now she's
going to come in the door just on the
right hand side so we're going to make
sure we crouched down because she can
turn round if you walk too quickly so
once the doll shots and she turns her
back to us
we can go over and kill her however we
like Garrett gone machete
do what you like right when she's down
make sure you pick up the safe key
that's very important and drag her quite
quickly into this wardrobe because there
are two guards that will come in and
check on her in about 20-30 seconds so
you're not really up against it
time wise place it's better to be quick
see if then sorry as they say okay we
retrace our steps we're going back down
where we were look that's her son by the
way so we've missed that quite well this
muscle tone Walworth and we're going to
go back to this door and back down to
where I said
to where I said there was a young lady
that we're going to work on next well
we're going to first we're going to run
back to our room our new room and change
our attire so for the next bit we need
to look like a police officer or
security security guard that it's not a
police officer is it remember where I
put the dead body there he is not dead
sorry knocked out not dead remember and
back again okay right we need to press
the fire alarm but she stood next to it
so we're going to just drop our weapon
there she'll go and then after a while
she'll go and get one of the other
officers which is just behind the wall
the second she moves we're going to
press the fire alarm as soon as we feel
safe now there we go and if you want you
can pick up your weapon I think I mixed
that completely oh well it doesn't
really matter and now we're going back
to where we first started so back across
this walkway again don't worry about
these two guards they're not first try
not to bump into them can annoy them and
back in the same door again
right this could be tricky depending on
what the guards are doing there's one
enforcer that's the one with the doctor
over the head so grab a cam if they
leave the room it is easy but if they
don't or they left the room but could
you see I was aiming across the room to
throw the can if they stay in the room I
just roll the can across room they all
turn around you have enough time to to
open the safe grab the memory stick and
duck back down if you need to but that's
it now it's just run to the end and
you're absolutely sorted so that took a
bit of time to figure out but it was
pretty good I really enjoyed that make
sure there's nobody on the way out cuz
there are always somebody there so we're
gonna go back that can be a bit
different but I'm sure you have an
entrance sorry I'm sure you have an exit
strategy by now you've been playing this
for months unless you just got the disc
version of course so once you get to the
jetty it's all over I'm gonna take the
front door I think risk it a bit more
and done that simple right well thanks
for your time
I'm hoping that's pretty good if it's
not please tell me in the comments if it
is worthwhile do as a favor and like it
and maybe even subscribe and I'll keep
doing these thanks for your time I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade peace out
[Music]